un instant donc on va recevoir booba on
va bien sûr comme je voulais dit parler
du classique ce que vous avez déjà eu
des clash
par ailleurs vous bernard montiel c'est
quoi le plus gros clash que vous ayez
alors en or du fait mais j'ai attaqué
plus tôt tf1 un moment vous savez quand
je me suis fâché avec eux et ça c'était
quand même un gros clash c'est que vous
avez balancé sur tous ses ballons
servier arthur arthur sait pas lire un
prompteur plein géant bon j'ai pas envie
de l'évoquer anna torv aviez dit que moi
younes avait dit que courbet se prenait
pour zorro à l'époque que le tapis était
avait de mauvaises affaires pas très
sérieusement bref ça c'est une vous êtes
lâchés commencer vous êtes lâchés comme
ça mais parce qu'il m'avait menti si
vous voulez moi je devenir maman tu y
tiennent mougeotte et monsieur dassier
qui était patron de l ess années j'avais
fait j'avais proposé une émission sur le
cinéma qui marrie passion et chacun se
renvoyait la balle non mais non c'est
lui qui décide ces lots de mâche un bon
voilà donc j'ai jamais eue ils ont donné
mon émission
le concept même à et une jeune fille on
va s'appeler sophie quelque chose sophie
très bien au final j'ai mal en tout cas
ce que j'ai vu c'est avec delpérier
votre pièce les justes avec delpérier a
way alexandre c'est beaucoup plus
sérieux en fait c'était un bouquin à
l'époque way qui s'appelait téléralité
justement à la suite de ces histoires
avec tf1 et j'avais dit la vérité c'est
à la vérité elle n'était pas compliqué
c'est que alexandre delpérier avait fait
croire à l'époque à etienne mougeotte le
pdg de tf1
ouais que deux ban qui était
hospitalisée à ce moment-là accepter
qu'il le remplace dans vidéo gag
ah ouais c'était faux non donc j'ai
l'écrit noir sur blanc et il a débarqué
dans l'émission 20h10 pétantes de
stéphane bern ouais il est arrivé il a
pris mon livre gens comme ça je dis bah
ça comment elle fait comment
salah gelabale embrouille lambiel à deux
balles c'est un bon attaquant mais on
nous raconte une histoire ont fait la
queue mais il a eu on a fait bon vivre
il a jeté mon livre parfait renom comme
j'avais comme ça arrête c'est comme si
j'analyse ça va tout et en afrique du
nord ouest a c'est toi qui tu as fait tu
avais dit qu elle rien tu vas pas mais
un coup de son prix non non tu parles de
ta bière et donc ouais mais et en plus
je reconnais là médard saint palais qui
s'emmêlent perrier il est sympa sauf
qu'il avait menti à ce moment là on a
très bien bref vous êtes très court et
concis
absolument sa voix c'est ça le plus gros
clash de ta vie ouais franchement ah
ouais quand même
ah ouais toi oui bon ça clashe heure mwh
alors ça m'a valu un jour il ya une
deuxième fois il s'est clashé parce
qu'ils l'ont fait faire 22 minutes du
jeu alors qu'il avait commandé 25 témoin
majeur mais c'est à dire que j'ai pas
arrêté j'ai jamais commencé donc si tu
étais tu ne t'es beau avec dans la rue
tout le monde parle de ça oui oui cyril
j'en passe syrie et l assumer un tu fais
parce que les gens que tu arrêtes de la
rue les gens qui arrêtent dans la rue en
tout cas tu les fais hyper bien benhaim
bonsoir c'est quoi votre plus gros cash
de benhaim franchement elles se classent
jeunes on sait bien c'est le propre de
beinheim ah oui non mais un très
honnêtement pour ça et pourquoi ça ne
m'intéresse pas quoi parce que c'est
perdre du temps donc je préfère je
méprise en fait la belle mépriser le
plus vous méprisez alors c'est quoi
votre nouveau clash non plus gros classe
je crois mais c'était mathieu j'embrasse
qui est pas là oui ce contrôle gardés
l'expert balle il est malheureusement
toi c'est pas le cas tu as fait un
paquet d'erreurs et à rien a primé
[Applaudissements]
vous soit le tiers de mes fans cette
pauvre ben haim le tir même demain
demain car hier à wave à un gardois le
tir ne se passe quoi un tiers de ouf je
suis pas sûr
[Applaudissements]
regardez clash pour soir dans les
classes juillet 98 finale de la coupe du
monde de foot
ouais je faisais petit aparté à aucun
service était journaliste à france soir
j'apportais n'a aucun service concerné
par le match de foot mais j'avais mal
compris tout le journal été
réquisitionnés pour un événement comme
ça j'aurais pu comprendre
bon du coup on me demande de faire de
participer alors j'avais prévu une
soirée chez moi avec tous mes potes
devant un écran géant pour regarder le
match est en fait je me trouve
réquisitionnés ou en seine-saint-denis
dans un gymnase pour regarder le match
est donc y griller tout m'asseoir avec
mes potes
donc je m'embrouille de ouf j'ai essayé
de virer d'ailleurs l'occasion avec le
directeur la rédaction de françois je me
retrouve en scène ce n'est dans un jeune
âge à notre insu s'anime dans un gymnase
où tout le monde se bat pour quoi et et
brûlent brésil n'ont donc tout le monde
était debout le brésil sur ses terres au
bois de boulogne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ouais bon l'été pour le pour le brésil
bizarrement et c'était un 1.8 schéma qui
est réquisitionnée pour diffuser le
match ou un petit à petit une petite
télévision dans le gymnase et dès la fin
du match au coup de sifflet final tout
est tellement déçu il a des bronches et
la télé non écran noir quand j'ai pas vu
la remise de la coupe j'ai absolument
rien vu je rentrais au journal sont
encore brouiller que directeur j'ai
écrit un journal papier qui n'est jamais
passé parce que c'était pour dire qu'en
fait le tour ont été brisées le papier
n'est jamais passé ça me flinguer ma
coupe du monde j'ai même pas vu la faute
d'un triste c'est bon ouais mais bon
c'est pas une grosse ombre us non non
non dans ce cas là les deux là les deux
là les deux là ils vont avoir des
grosses embrouilles
on dirait garder on dirait le père et sa
fille de votre mère ou gilles verdez un
peu vénère comme ça c'est vrai on ne
connaît pas son père mais sur qui doit
il ou non ça vient même région tout ça
et bien sûr il tenait la famille eto'o
mais c'est pas vrai bien sûr je dis ça
au hasard sur une coupe et je passe tout
le temps devant chez elle je suis de là
bas et tout ça alors prenez l'entraîneur
de foot de ma vie non c'est on est on
est on est on est à fond sur l'a6 où
s'abritent votre oncle alors les simca
dit christine kelly mc cotation briller
les écoutent oui ben en fait mon clash a
été silencieux je me suis levé et je me
suis et je suis parti six studios
d'europe 1 c'était en octobre 2009 je
l'est avec laurent baffie
je les regarde et je regardais et je
veux raconter quelqu'un lui qu entre
lille et lyon vi aura pas non plus
refaire le monde la signalétique existe
déjà et elle a le mérite d'exister c'est
tellement facile de rejeter de ne pas
éduquer son enfant de ne pas dire bon
argument ce que demandent ces dames
c'est simplement que vous l'entendiez et
que vous lui disiez peut-être oui vous
avez raison nous allons été essayé
d'étudier la question la signalétique a
le mérite d'exister on peut pas la
critique elle a déjà le mérite d'exister
mais que tout est en ordre de critiquer
là si jamais lyon méritait qu'on fait
c'est d'un million
[Applaudissements]
non l'approché directe lui dit tu vois
je suis a demandé pourquoi je suis parti
je n'ai jamais dit dix ans plus tard je
vais vous dire pourquoi je sois pas dit
que nous parce qu'il y avait un
programmateur qui m'avait supplié de
venir à cette émission
j avais dit non j'adore la m papillon
finalement on m'avait expliqué comment
l'émission serait pas oui le président
du csa ne voulait pas que j'y aille
personne ne voulait que j'y aille
j'y vais au m'expliquer comment ça se
passe une émission pas en direct pas
d'interview au téléphone etc c'est dans
ce contexte et après finalement
l'émission dépend des tons te donne
quelqu'un au téléphone tu sens que c'est
de la magouille
tu sais pas comment ça se sait pas
quelle copine de qui appelle est
vraiment c'était pas du tout ce qui
était l objet photographique maintenant
la donne alors c'est ce qui est rigolo
c'est que le lendemain il m'a envoyé un
bouquet mais on est actionnaire on était
potes avant on était embrassement lobala
jusqu'à mardi mais la très libre et lui
tu perds compris vous a sauté dessus a
nommé mme ont tous sauté dessus alors
qu'en fait c'était une sorte de coup
monté contre un membre du csa à côté ça
le truc c'était dont plus personne n'ose
attaquer aux saisons avec les 3 millions
qu'ils ont et on va voir de très bons
avocats
oui bonsoir soir comme vous le savez je
ne suis pas le roi du clash gm veut la
version de valérie benaïm et au masculin
c'était dragon draps sera rappelé à son
train de séduire une fille a le copain
qui démarque et rappelle suis pas laissé
démonter alors non non franchement et on
a hot américo n'est pas s'il vous plaît
comme le regarde regarde
et puis le bras mais mon dieu est certes
je fais tout aussi dans leur jeunesse ou
tu fais quoi on commence en je fais pas
ici ceux qui sont clos c'est la folie
tout est bon chez lui
mais d'abord de dons
là tu parles bien data pour toi
[Musique]
deux jours d'enchères sortir
je joue
m
d'accord
ces dégagements switches dans la chambre
à 100
allez viens de remarquer une nouvelle
gare cas dans un magnéto s'est quant à
elle au top avec le tweak n'avons pas vu
cela
j'avais plein de qualités novelli c'est
quoi votre ont mouillé alors c'était le
14 février derniers mois pour la saint
valentin
ouais ou l'a61 chez fleuriste là à
boulogne à côté ouais chercher un
bouquet de fleurs pour matthieu
delormeau way et j'ai mis ma voiture en
warning got us devant le fleuriste pour
aller vite je me suis que ça allait
aller vite et en fait ça a mis plus de
temps que prévu parce que tous les maris
étaient en train d'acheter des fleurs à
leur femme et donc du coup j'entends une
dame une personne âgée qui crie dehors
pied que j'étais dans le quartier oui
mais moi en mode curieuse je mets ma
tête est en fait serment qu'elle
s'adressait nom et elle m'a dit vous
vous prenez pour qui y est avec votre
voiture en warning
je vais vous crevez votre de petite
conne normal vous connaissez ces retours
neigeux et d'imagés vous crevez autre
chose vieille conne non non mais là je
me suis dit bon j'ai pas le temps plus
en retard pour venir ici et donc je suis
parti mais morale à cette histoire c'est
quoi bah c'est pas parce que nous sommes
des personnes âgées
je m'adresse à toutes les vieilles dames
et à tous les vieux magot à gauche vous
n'avez pas l'immunité vous n'avez pas le
totem vous ne pouvez pas vous permettre
de parler mal aux gens ce que vous êtes
vieux qu'on va pas vous tapez
[Applaudissements]
chanter est faible à l'aller sortait
alors est ce parce que les personnes
âgées nous respecte les personnes âgées
oui bien entendu et on ne tape pas les
personnages etc et gilles on est
d'accord
oulala jamais jamais jamais mais à côté
d'un clash comme ça le mien va paraître
dérisoire on ne tarde personnes
meilleurs voilà on ne tape personne
violant viaggio lopez dans le public est
là qui est un ami voilà il est d'accord
et moi maintenant de ta personne de hopa
jo de ta personne et kelly ça ça va 100
ça va pas oui alors moi j'ai choisi un
des clash que j'ai eu sur le plateau
c'était vois mes classes les plus loin
j'ai pris celui avec patrice carteron un
jugement en appel mais confiant donc on
s'était un peu embrouillé mais bon il
est marrant regardez
[Applaudissements]
je pense que fut gagnant fort mais je
parle d'un combat et revient d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
t'as pas regarder occupé tenir
ouais donc il fallait bien que le fait
bien vous étiez un peu inquiet quand
même un peu regardé en me demandant de
me calmer vous saviez pas s'il avait pas
d'eau non il est cool quoi il écrit vous
êtes une banale bagarre après non non
non et puis après il m'a fait un petit
message tout ça irait bien voir
combattre le voir perdre son 4e bouquet
mais vous vous avez pas d effectuer
d'affaires toutes les personnes de
trouver pas dissous cette chaussure
isabelle ses nouvelles à raison ça sur
moi alors à moi généré je n'irai jamais
tapé une personne âgée mais cela n'a pas
construit c'est qu'à la fin tu as dit
taper les personnes âgées alors que tous
les dieux reste non parce que la dame
m'a menacé oui parce que vous êtes des
personnes âgées immunisés on a craint
pas les gens comme ça gratuit mais vous
mais il faut pas taper les personnes
ayant bien voilà social le mérite non
mais non
[Applaudissements]
elle fut envoyée le grand frère sur la
cour de ma mère c'est françois difficile
mais je vais envoyer le gonfleur